everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we're going to be
continuing our series on in-depth
analysis of the Sicilian defense and
we're going to be going over one of the
most popular and most requested lines
that comes from the Sicilian defense and
that is the Knight Dorf variation it's
one of the most well respected defenses
that you'll see in chess it's played on
all levels of chess
even up to the top you've probably seen
many of Garry Kasparov's games Bobby
Fischer's games to players that really
really enjoy this defense it's one of
the most sound offenses that you will
see there's so much theory on it I feel
like it would be a disservice not to do
a video on it and kind of explain some
of the the concepts and some of the main
lines and ideas to think about when
you're playing so it starts out with
pawn to e4 pawn to c5 again this is the
Sicilian defense Knight f3 simple
development pawn to d6 pawn d4 after
black captures white recaptures blacks
now going to come to f6 for simple
development and after the Knights going
to come to c3 the knight or defense
continues with pawn to a6 and this is
really where we're going to start
getting into different variations of the
knight or defense now if you're not too
familiar with the Sicilian defense or
the knight or variation in general you
may look at this and say you know a six
is this really one of the most respected
defenses and all of chests it's just a
little move a six right here and the
answer is yes and as far as the Sicilian
in general keep in mind the Sicilian is
a very very sharp line typically you see
both sides trying to control the other
side White's trying to control the Kings
side will actually trying to control the
Queen side trying to control this
semi-open c-file really trying to attack
the Queen side of white we're typically
white is castle
from here this pawn here on a six has a
lot of different ideas the first thing
as you can see it's blocking off this
outpost on both of his Knights this
Knight can't come here and I can't come
here there's not a lot of good squares
for the night to come to right now we
are still blocking
with our pawn here on b7 it cannot come
to this c6 square and it would really
like to come to this b5 square also keep
in mind that since black does have these
light squares open attacking the King
here a lot of times in other variations
of the Sicilian the white Bishop really
likes to come down to b5 and harass the
heck out of the black King in this
variation obviously you can see it's
blocking that as well so not only is it
a great pawn placement as far as
blocking our opponent anytime you can
block your opponent from some of the
themes they would like to do that's a
good thing not always going forward with
what you want but if you can stop them
that's good as well but it also has
other ideas as well typically black
would like to bring his pawn push it
forward to b5 again black in the
Sicilian is always trying to to
counter-attack it's it's one of the most
aggressive defenses that black has you
definitely don't want to play it if
you're passive so you know being able to
push forward with b5 really starting to
push on the attack on the Queen side
it's definitely helpful for that once
black does have this pawn here on b5 he
does have different options he can
always bring now a knight here on C
fours an outpost he obviously still has
the night here on c5 because of his his
pawn there on d6 so he has all these
different options obviously once the
pawn comes to b5 as well he can also
bring his LightSquared Bishop into the
action so he can bring it to b7 if he
wants to start to put a lot of pressure
once he has both of his minor pieces he
can now get his rook involved into the
game trying to control again this
semi-open C file so black has a lot of
different ideas just from this simple
move of a6 now obviously we do want to
talk about white White has a lot of
different options just from this
particular standpoint as we look at it
right here in the knight or variation
and that's kind of where we're going to
go we're going to go a lot of different
areas we do have the old mainline
defense that you've seen a lot from from
white as far as countering this you do
have the new modern line that you'll see
a lot and then you have another
variation called the fissure shows an
attack and that's kind of another
variation we're going to look at so
we're going to go ahead and start
off with the old main line in any night
or defense from white after black plays
a six now the old main line from white
starts with Bishop to g5 now this is the
most aggressive line that white has
against the Sicilian obviously keeping
in mind that Sicilian is very aggressive
typically analogies from white you may
see a little bit more passive move
instead of again this is the old main
line nowadays you may see you know
Bishop to e3 instead of to g5 nowadays I
personally feel like some of the GM's
don't try to get too cute they try to
kind of play subtle in the beginning
trying to really build up strong
structure going to this deep analysis of
middle game that's fine Danny but any
time I see someone come out top level
play that just plays Bishop to g5
basically saying I'm going all-out
I'm going as aggressive as I can against
the you know Sicilian defense it's
really it's really really fun to see
there's not a lot of drawls in these
games there's so many tactical errors
that can be made it's just really really
fun to watch so personally I play
against a lot of aggressive players so I
see this line more times than not if
you've played the knight or defense
you've probably seen it a lot so from
here black does have a few different
options one of his options is to play
pawn to e6 again getting ready to
obviously defend this Knight with either
his Queen on d8 he can always bring his
bishop here to e7 to defend it more
likely than not after black plays pawn
to e6 why it's not going to to capture
obviously the higher you get up in chess
typically players don't like to give up
their bishops early on as far as trading
in with their Knights and that is simply
because you can open up the board a lot
easier than you can close it since
bishops do better in open games if
someone has a bishop pair typically they
will try to open up the game and then
they will have a very very big advantage
if they do have that bishop pair so just
something to to keep in mind in the back
your head
now from here if we look at from white
if we think about the ideas that really
white has as you can see the bishop
can't really as far as being aggressive
if again if you're going to play this
Bishop to g5 it means you're kind of
being aggressive so there's no reason
now to play Bishop to b2 it's kind of a
little bit too passive you know bring it
to c4 it's trying to eye down on that f7
Square but again the e6 pawn is
protecting it it can't come to b5 not a
lot of good squares so typically you
start to either see you know pawn to f4
some players play you know Queen to f3
if they're not comfortable pushing the
pawn forward but the most common is pawn
to f4 again really trying to push on the
King side white will eventually castle
on the Queen side and really try to just
Massacre black on the King side now from
here black does have a few different
options one of his moves he can come to
be 7 as we talked about before again
defending his night here on f6 from here
white can now bring his Queen to f3
again developing his pieces getting
ready to castle on the the Queen side
from here black has two different
options one is to bring his Queen to b6
again you have to counter play you can't
just stay passive the entire time as the
Sicilian that's really not what it's
there for so again putting a lot of
pressure on this b2 pawn and from here
white is going to castle on the Queen
side now from here black has a few
options but he can always bring his
Knight to d7 again trying to add more
pressure onto this knight on f6
obviously he can also if he wants to
push forward in time with pawn to e5 now
besides playing Bishop to e7 a lot of
times black has the option of bringing
his Queen to b6 if you've ever heard of
the poisoned pawn in the knight or
defense this is what it refers to
bringing the Queen to be set this is one
of Garry Kasparov's go-to defenses so
anytime he comes out and says hey in the
knight or defense this is pretty much
what I'm going to play this is what I've
studied and what I think it's the best I
pretty much am going to agree with him
he was pretty good at chess so take it
for
that what you will and play whichever
variation you want but from here White's
going to continue with Queen to d2 he's
going to allow the Queen to come to b2
and take this pawn on b2 in exchange for
trying to control the center of the
board with development and his pieces
and pawns so the Queen's not going to
come to queen to b2 and the rooks is
going to come to b1 obviously the Queen
is going to have to kick back on a three
and then why it's going to start to push
forward you can either push forward with
f5 or it can push forward with E for
keep in mind from white if you do see
this or you're playing against this
black is now up in material so you did
not sacrifice this extra pawn on b2 for
nothing anytime you're going to gambit
apiece or give up a piece or pawn any
type of material it needs to have some
sort of compensation in this case why
it's really going to try to pound away
on the Kings side of black so as you can
see the dynamics here this is this is a
very very aggressive line for both sides
white can no longer castle on the the
Queen side his rook has moved so again
this is going to be a little bit
different there's a hole now on
semi-open file on the C file White has a
semi-open file on the B file so the
Queen side is going to be fireworks all
over the place
and why it's controlling the center of
the board even though what black is up
in material so you know gierek is both
enjoy this but you know it does get kind
of crazy just keep that in mind if you
do play the poisoned pawn variation
another variation that you may see is
the out hidden time variation and that
starts out with Bishop to e7 as we
talked about before in the in the
mainline and then the Queen is going to
come to f3 again but from here instead
of bringing the Queen out to b6 as we
talked about before or even c7 if you
want to from here blacks going to play
pawn to h6 now I know many people they
anytime the your opponent tries to
pinned down your knight you just
immediately play h6 or you play a six
depending on if he's pinning down the
knight to the queen or the king in this
case this is probably one of the more
wild crazy chaotic variations that you
will see so we'll go ahead and get into
it again
if they if white chooses to exchange any
time someone exchanges their Bishop for
unite early on hey that's a win for you
again try to open up the game and really
use your your bishop pair typically you
won't see someone do that if they know
what they're doing if they're familiar
with chess so in this case you might see
the bishop come back to h4 again this is
the main line in the Aventine variation
blacks now going to play pawn to g5
again really breaking this up now as you
can start to see already black typically
castles on the Kings side and the
Sicilian defense so this is pretty much
just breaking everything up especially
after you know pawn takes on g5 so you
can already see blacks not looking to
castle on the Kings side anymore so
anytime someone basically says hey I'm
not going to castle where I'm planning
on to and none of these pieces the Queen
Bishop and Knights are developed so it's
going to take me a long time to castle
on the other side with this C file open
you pretty much know black saying hey
I'm going all out I may not even Castle
and there's just going to be fireworks
so if you like chaos hey try this
defense out it's kind of entertaining so
from here blacks going to play Knight to
d7 a very important move getting his
Knight out of the way also getting ready
if he wants to to come to e5 and he's
also allowing the bishop and the Queen
now to both eye down on this dark square
diagonal if he wants to take on here on
g5 he can also take here on h4 if this
pawn moves so very important move to
bring the knight back to d7 from here
White's going to actually cache her
capture on e6 and black is going to
recapture with his pawn here on e6 now
if whites not too familiar he could
definitely make a mistake here if he
does not see that it's actually a good
move to take on e6 Bobbsey if black
captures you may be thinking you know I
don't understand why would white give up
material here as you can see he's really
opening up all these lines here's Queen
can now come to h5
and the king here on e 1 the king is
going to have to come to f8 and then the
LightSquared Bishop can come to b5 now
even if you look at this you'd say you
know Kevin I don't understand why would
you bring your your Bishop to b5 like
you're just asking for it to be taken
right here with this pawn here on a 6
but what it does is it also allows you
to open up the door if you want to
castle on the Kings side you can also
just bring the rook to f1 it's going to
be really really hard for for black to
cope with all of the stuff that you have
going on here obviously White has the
Queen here on h5 a lot going on from
Fischer actually came up with the best
reputation of this and that is instead
of taking with the pawn here on b5 is
actually to play rook to h7 this is
really the saving grace for black it
really sets up if he needs to defend if
the the rook comes to f1 it kind of
gives him the ability to swing this over
if he needs to obviously he can you know
bring his King to g8 if he needs to but
it really protects this key square here
of the f7 squared as we talked about
before you know if the rook was on f1
and then the Queen came down to F 2 it
would be checkmate so this rook here on
8 7 is going to be huge obviously as we
talked about before white gave up
material playing this this Knight here
taking on e6 and with black recapturing
so you can see this this definitely
doesn't look good for black I'm not
going to sit here and say this is you
know this is a fantastic situation
but black is up in material and he does
have the ability to to save face here so
Fischer has played this and he says this
is a legitimate play h7 to protect the
house here if you will but you
definitely are going to have to be you
know aggressive for black we're
definitely gonna have to start to push
forward obviously you're attacking this
bishop here on b5 White's going to have
to do something about that black is
definitely going to have to start
to get his other pieces involved really
start to get some counterplay or he will
get crushed here on the kingside
especially if white decides to castle on
the queen's i get both of the rooks
involved it's definitely going to be
chaotic but I kind of told you that
going into this variation so this is the
old mainline we're going to go ahead and
now get into the the new mainline that
you'll see a lot in high-level the new
main line starts with Bishop to e3 in
this position a little less aggressive
than if the bishop came down to two g5
it's still not blocked by the pawn
structure obviously the pawn has come
out to be four so it won't be blocked
off but typically in high-level play
nowadays you'll see a little bit more
passive approach not to say that this
Sicilian is passive but compared to
Bishop to g5 typically players at top
level aren't trying to play the most
aggressive openings anymore that's not
to say that III is not a good move it's
just not nearly as aggressive as the old
mainline from here black has a few
options so if you do see the bishop come
to e3 you do have a few options you
could always bring your pawn to e5
really try to you know block this night
here on d4 he really has no problems
coming back to be through anyway this is
kind of where he's comfortable from here
black can start to just develop his
pieces again Bishop to e6 obviously
trying to get his knight involved into
the game trying to bring his rook to c8
trying to control this semi open file
he's eventually going to bring his
bishop into the game over here maybe
Bishop to e7 castle on the Kings side is
still trying to attack on the Queen side
so still some of the same theory behind
you know the typical Sicilian knight or
defense from here you may see the pawn
come to f3 trying to only not only
defend this pawn here on e4 but also
trying to stop the knight here coming to
g4 as another variation that we'll get
to in a second instead of efore you can
always play Knight to g4 kind of you
know annoying if you see it as white
knight coming to g4 which is why I
actually prefer playing that so this is
why you might see
upon coming to f3 again if you do see
pawn coming to f3 this typically means
that White's not going to castle on the
kingside if he does this is not really
aggressive you might want to push it
forward to f4 open up the F file for
your rook here playing f3 and then
castling on the kingside is kind of weak
sauce you're really not helping your
protection of the king side and you're
not really also making it aggressive for
your rook as well so this typically
means they're going to castle on the
Queen side from here black can continue
with Knight to d7 again trying he can
always bring it to c6 if he wants to but
this will allow him to bring his rook
right away to c8 and really control that
long semi-open file from here you may
see Queen come to d2 getting ready to
castle on the Queen side from here black
can really start to push forward he can
bring his pawn to b5 again he can always
bring his rook to c8 if he wants to a
lot of times you will see this push to
b5 right away kind of hoping that white
will castle on the Queen side first and
then because if you see that then black
can push forward with b3 kind of an
annoying move again white now has to
move his knight here
so instead a lot of times from white you
will see a3 first or you may even see a
for first putting a lot of pressure on
black trying to have him decide where he
wants to go now obviously if these come
off the board then white may revisit the
option of castling on the King side
obviously if he's going to give up this
diagonal excuse me this long a file or
semi open a file it's going to be much
harder to protect the Queen side so
depending on his idea of how he wants to
attack he can either castle on the Queen
side or he can push up with this a pawn
to a3 a lot of times you may also just
see a 4 really trying to put a lot of
pressure on black so very common just to
see a 4 now if we come back here as we
talked about before black has the option
of coming forward with e5 he can also
either just come to
or a lot of times actually recommend
playing Knight to g4 this is kind of a
pain in the rear for white obviously
you're trying to you know exchange
pieces you're trying to exchange your
knight for the bishop is if you talked
about before early on this is
advantageous if you can trade those off
even though they are you know
technically both worth three points
now this Knight is being protected by
the bishop here on c7 if you've watched
the other dragon variation you know that
from here white can always come down and
check the King here on b5 but the great
thing about the knight or defense is
this pawn here on a6 again very very key
outpost here on b5 it's protecting so
black no longer has to worry about the
bishop coming down to b5 which makes the
night here on g4 that much more fun to
harass the bishop here on e3 so from
here white can continue with Bishop to
g5 black can continue with h6
then Bishop h4 again these are standard
moves pawn to d5 white Bishop is just
going to be kicked back Black's now
going to play Bishop to g7 the reason I
like this is this is a way if your
opponent starts with pawn or excuse me
Bishop to e3 basically going into the
mate the new main line of these Sicilian
defense Knight or variation from white
basically saying out you know I don't
want to be that aggressive well this is
a way to say you know what I'm gonna
take that and I'm going to be even more
aggressive with it as you can tell black
has the ability to start pushing forward
on the Queen side but blacks already
starting to push forward on the Kings
side as well which as you can tell this
is going to be a much more aggressive
defense from black his king defense is
going to be not as strong he's really
going to be looking to push forward
white doesn't have as strong a center
control here again he can always push
forward with his pawn on e5 kick this
Knight off he can start to develop his
pieces so this is going to be a very
very aggressive line from from black
here now also keep him on if you look at
this that white does still have the
option here to
castle on the kingside so you're not
really sure where why it's going to end
up he that hasn't moved any of his pawns
on the F file so there's a lot of
different options this is kind of why I
like this idea in the new main line now
the next idea is the Fischer chosen
attack it's a it's different variation
than we've seen before so I'll go ahead
and get into that now you won't see this
variation as much but anytime Fischer's
named after variation I feel obligated
to to talk about it since he spent time
to analyze it and deemed it necessary to
to play a lot we'll go ahead and talk
about it and that is instead of actually
bringing the dark squared Bishop into
the game it's going to bring the light
squared Bishop into the game he's going
to attack this f7 Square right away now
obviously this is the weakest Square
from black in the early part of the game
so first thing black wants to do is he
wants to for that attack he's going to
play pawn to e6 typical logical move
again making it very hard to continue to
attack this from here White's going to
push back he's going to play Bishop to
b3 this is very very common for Fischer
anytime you've seen him play he likes to
bring his bishop out to c4 and then he
kicks it back to b3 and just tries to
harass this long light diagonal the
entire game now why is he played this
right away you know he could always
castle on the King side but he really
doesn't want you know the pawn to come
to b5 with tempo so instead he just goes
ahead and brings his Bishop back to b3
he doesn't want it he could do them
either way but he's like you know what
I'm going to come back to b3 because if
he doesn't come push forward with b5 we
may want to have different options we
may want to castle on the Queen side we
may want to do something else that's why
the bishops coming back to b3 first and
not allowing black to push forward and
making that choice for white so from
here typically you'll see either you
know Bishop to e7 if you're really
aggressive you may just want to start
pushing forward with b5 really starting
that attack here white can do a lot of
things he can bring his bishop if you
want
down to g5 he can castle on the kingside
so a lot of different ideas from both
different sides again you won't see this
as often as the old main line and the
new main line but if you do see it or
you play even as white and you want to
change it up a little bit definitely
feel free to give this your shot and let
me know what you guys think so this is
the the knight or defense definitely
tons and tons of theory behind it I
definitely recommend checking out the
website looking at some of the famous
games that have been used playing these
see some of the the ideas and concepts
that they used in the middle game going
into the in-game some phenomenal games
that have been played using the knight
or defense and even if you keep up with
tournaments nowadays it's played all the
time so definitely check some of those
out and be thinking about these ideas
that you watch the game like oh wow
that's that's totally cool it's
definitely more entertaining once you
know what's going on and what they're
thinking about during the game so
hopefully you guys enjoyed the video be
tons of more later on definitely check
out the website if you haven't already
and I'll see you guys in the next video
thanks for watching